we've just got time to go for the visit
to the big red chair hello hello hello
hi what's your name James James dr.
James and what do you do I'm a civil
servant a civil servant nothing in
London here yes in London are you from
the London air no I live in London but
I'm originally from Suffolk oh it's a
Suffolk massif in the song probably ya
know what school did you go to so I went
to Brandon oh so yeah I with the primary
school okay did we know each other yeah
[Applause]
hello yeah James yes me that's the one
and now you're talking to him honestly
he's right oh my god can we not flip
them and just get them out of here
do you miss Ari or do you boy yeah I did
but it's leaves let it be about okay
then we'll flip you and then okay cool
yes yeah when we were younger ed used to
come around to my house and yell at you
saying we used to be quite good mates
and I remember one time one time he's
come round for tea and I forgotten to
tell mum who's a vegetarian at that
point anyway and so mum cooked
I think the sausage and mash for tea and
Ed said you know after the meal these
are the best sausages I've ever tasted
you know where did you get them from a
mum had to lie because she had no clue
sorry
first time I ever had me and also the
first time I ever watch The Simpsons
episode was around yeah we can be
reunited backstage
I feel like Cilla black on surprise
surprise
[Applause]
Renda me see have a seat have a seat
dude
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's all we've got time for that
reunited it's beautiful
[Music]